Lula is back
the former president will return to
power in Brazil for the third time he
takes on a deeply divided country and a
troubled economy he's pledged to boost
growth with a campaign against hunger
and a program of government-led
Investments but everyone from investors
to small town residents are wondering
how he's going to come up with the money
to make it all happen he promises to
keep monthly handouts to the poor to
increase minimum wage above inflation
and to exempt more people from income
tax but more public spending puts him on
a crash course against Congress and the
Central Bank who've been trying to rein
in inflation take the monthly cash
handouts people really rely on these to
make ends meet and they're due to be
reduced in December but to keep the
program going for another year it would
cost the government 52 billion rail or
9.7 billion dollars Bula needs to
convince lawmakers to change the most
important fiscal buffer in place a
spending cap that prevents the
government from increasing its spending
more than the prior Year's inflation
rate that needs to be approved soon by
the end of the year and under
bolsonaro's Administration so Lula is
going to have to negotiate with
lawmakers and government to make that
happen the soul comes at a time when
gross debt is seen remaining at 80
percent of GDP much higher than Regional
neighbors like Chile or Mexico so the
current government is going to have to
decide spending rules quickly
[Music]